[Music]
if you notice like on tick tock there's
this big thing with like the ick and
girls saying all these things that give
them the ick and then guys in the
comments getting really heated because
they're like we can't do anything what
are we supposed to do i'm just laughing
at a girl being like yeah i hate it when
guys lick horses [ __ ] and the dudes
in the comments being like i don't get
it what are we supposed to do what are
we supposed to do about that the
craziest one that i saw is this girl
saying she got the ick when her
boyfriend got robbed dude all the
comments are from other girls being like
yeah that would give me the ick too and
guys being like what the [ __ ]
i don't get it
yeah i would never be with a dude that
would get robbed that is so funny dude
it's so funny that is so [ __ ] funny
to get your [ __ ] took and then
afterwards like that was super
unattractive by the way well i didn't
choose to do it yeah i gotta be honest
with you that was like kind of really
gross i'm down to give you a second
chance just like never get robbed again
yeah
hey man last day kind of ended weird i
think we could make up for it yeah i
don't know watching you get robbed was
like kind of pathetic
i don't know if this can continue
really sad and makes me think you're a
beta male to be honest
sigma male mindset getting robbed on
purpose
this money ain't [ __ ] to me watch this
you just pull up the skid row who
[ __ ] wants it dude the thing on love
island with the horse's ass it was funny
because later in that episode davide
kisses ekinsu and then she was like how
does it taste and he's like like turkish
dessert and i just kept imagining him
saying that after licking a horse's head
oh my god davide you ate it how does it
taste like a turkish dessert it would
have been funny actually if he said like
a horse's ass like a horse's [ __ ]
gemma's playing games though like the
fact that she's sitting there the the
dude jackson she's like we should get
out of this area like implying that yeah
oh i thought she was implying that she
still had feelings probably
actually i can't shame her for playing
games because that's what we want we
just talked about how we want people to
[ __ ] it off yeah yeah yeah that's true i
want some drama yeah like when ecken sue
was sneaking around yeah i don't know if
you're there yet but yeah are you when
they snuck up i just saw that hide away
or whatever or the nest i mean or
whatever the [ __ ] paris the terrorist
when that dude started rapping oh my god
see we need more of that
car crash when he was like
and they were like spit some bars and i
was like here we go and then he went for
it that [ __ ] party silence of like
and then he boofs the last line he like
stutters and like does that like nervous
laugh i was like oh shudder through my
whole body whenever that [ __ ] happens
like why wouldn't you just like pawn it
off you just go like no mate we maybe we
have a few drinks so we get into it
later and then you just like introduce
it later he went right into it he's just
like all right raw that makes me wonder
i wonder how wes is doing with his music
he's like going on tour where's nelson
yeah yeah he's still got a 3.8 million
monthly listeners dude i think that's
from his uh i think a lot of that is
from the nice to meet you
saying no some drive
uh yeah i had nothing else about love
island but i just remembered that i
would lick a horse's ass it's clean i
just like her logic
it's clean so just you just love horses
just admit it yeah i have a weird thing
for horses yeah it's clean you're a
horse girl uh it's clean they eat grass
or my camera just i think i just
murdered the battery on my camera that's
fine i got another one hell yeah dude
let's good thing we're in studio today
yeah man it feels good feels good to be
in the studio i can't believe we
set up our offices in the studio
seriously to do this
i don't know what i just can't i can't
stop going on vacation you know i'm
addicted man i can't stop traveling dude
i was dying because i missed it in the
moment when you were like i haven't left
town in a month and a half
and then they just ate you up for that
the comments on the in the app were like
this [ __ ] guy i haven't left in a
month and a half
oh because they're like
like dude like like they're
saying like
what do you mean like i haven't left my
place in like a year what are you
talking about i haven't left in a month
and a half
the one of the comments just quoted you
and just said this guy
oh come on that's not fair at all dude
how is that fair bro like i don't think
we travel a lot you're in a different
[ __ ] city every single weekend that's
why i'm laughing because it's not even
that like what you said was inflammatory
i just loved that
they wouldn't whoever this was wouldn't
even give you that they're just waiting
just waiting this guy
this [ __ ] guy i'm sorry there's
[ __ ] a million weddings people
getting i don't get you know
people trying to lock it in dude yeah
plus i mean like you're not gonna turn
down a pj right yeah plus
you gotta take it out like you didn't
buy it for no reason use it or lose it
you gotta take out your dad's half a
million dollar cessno i mean like if
you're not going to
who's not all right for a plane that's
not that expensive
i'll stand behind that oh wait on the go
scroll down on this luke there's like a
there's like something about double
decker airplane seats that they're
yeah i saw that [ __ ] that was so funny
yeah and they're like you probably
haven't seen that on your private jet
and i was like yeah my
my plane has one seat and it's just the
game of thrones yeah
no way this is not real
is this real they don't actually want to
do this do they if there was something
to be afraid of in a [ __ ] plane crash
like
this is it this is so
illegal and just immoral nah i mean like
i think someone said this already but
farting on the person behind you is
going to be so funny that's all you're
going to hear on a plane
can you imagine being middle seat on
this [ __ ] oh my god how
claustrophobic that would be
oh
dude terrified the whole time i've taken
so many shitty flights i'm starting to
know them by model oh this is an airbus
a321 oh bro i
i got on the flight here and i realized
like it's kind of a newer plane i'm
gonna look up the model number because i
do that too i don't know for some reason
i'm interested and it was a 737 max
eight oh oh dude i'll i [ __ ] freak
out when i read that
have you been on one yeah they're flying
them all the time now yeah they've been
like since that whole thing but yeah i i
had a flight like late last year that
was a max eight and i was just like
i wish i didn't check i know i was
pretty i was pretty spooked at first but
weirdly it was a super smooth flight
like weirdly you could tell that that
you know the newer plane did more for
like sound i don't know dissipation or
something like oh bro
like really pleasant and smooth even the
like oxygen levels are better on those
planes i think like they don't compress
you as hard yeah the airbus a321s
however those shits are loud bro it is
yeah they're the worst also i have like
a very depressing stat but basically
those chairs unless you are
5 10 your feet don't perfectly reach the
ground so it's like really hard to sleep
in those chairs
no way really yes so you can't point
your feet firmly on the ground they're
just a little bit hanging off yeah so
like it forces you to kind of like slide
forward and then like you're just your
lower back is just getting blown out
pause no pause yes homo whatever your
back is getting blown out by this chair
yeah dude mile high club i heard the
most like airplane like npc thing on on
i took a red eye on thursday and this
dude's like hey man do you mind
switching uh so i could sit with my wife
it's the exact same chair i'm just you
know i'm just uh i'm just back i'm on
one row behind you and the guy goes sure
the inside of my eyelids will look the
same in that chair
hell yeah that's dad [ __ ] right there
makes no difference to me still closing
my eyes
that's great
you